今日は外れ社長です皆さん食品サンプルというものをご存知でしょうか
ネット欄とかにもあると思うんですけどもあってかもその出てくる食品そっくりの
サンプルがあるんですけどそれを食品サンプルと言いますけ
もう最近ですね食品サンプルめちゃくちゃリアルで物によってまぁ本郷のの食べ物と
食品サンプル三役がつかないほどリアルの時にあったりするねまったくし思いました
会え用の食品サンプルの中に本物が混じっててもわからないです今日はやっていきたい
と思います上で今日の彼はですねちょっとタイガーのショッちんさんでここにあると
思うんですけども僕コレ一つも実ないですねいただき買ってない後輩に入ってファイが
遊んでなんかリアルっぽいショッピンサッカーを買いまくってくれたのでまずは
ジャンミですこの中に一つだけ僕ボールの食べ物があるらしいです
は兄弟虫呼びましょう政治お願いしまーす
宜しくお願いしますよろしくお願い
ボディダンパー4代目を選んだんですよねこの技ではです奴はれてずっと
どうもこの合うけそけそいい感じじゃないはい初めに何種類あります25種類になり
ます
25種類なんかよのなかの一つだけが本物本物です私がセロ当てればいいと2ですね
これ食べれると思ったものを口にしていただければ食べるっニッパ香りまあその時は
なんとかしたはいじゃあヌー
ん
ダメダメダメだなぁあれはこれが普通じゃなくてこれはサンプルですって言うのはそう
いう方にどの決してってのがって食べるねそれが版プレイだとしても私
ターンヌーやわからないけど頑張って見ぬふり
じゃあねじゃあいった分 b-king でとか
ファーストフード送りすぎたところあると思いますよなんでそして私がありましたら
なあねっ
ハンバーガー
聞いてどういうか
gacchi 使ったなっちょちょっと何かあったな
いや恐れ業もまじっすなじゃあ金城除く動画でどうしてもとか寝起き沿い時は
37性が出てしないハンバーガーとラーメンはもう外したらしくいませんことしたいっ
誰かせて頂きますお願いしますじゃあこの位置からね
あっ規律はありです切れたりあります
3切れますそこから見させていただきます何となく物に把握しましょうか
ばなんだろはいビーマンたいパプリカ赤
エッジ論減ってブドウマスカットやクッキー3種類
ていた
でも洋艦これは秘密まです神爪って何でしょう
中にあんこが子様丸な王様風邪もなんか
ゼリーピューどれ
ブーブー言っなっぷるアーレンこっちっ予定
ハンガー5件あってここにあるなんだこれ快くラグビーです
不ジェリーかはいそういうわけでここに写っているのが今日出てくる消費サンプル等だ
みんなはどれが本物かわかるかな
その小さなの味噌で頑張って考えてみようね
始めも一緒に考えるよ正解はエンディングの後だよとは定
でみてねおねしゃす飛ばされてくださいはいこんなの撮れが一緒にだけが本物という
ことか
はい
あのーん
バナナ絶対ちゃながら見るからにヤバイもんだってこんな編
まだは違いますございますファンならたまらん
はい強い違いますはい俺が作ったお花っていいとさーんすぎですね
ん
ブーバーカール n 4 day
弁護これはね今切開いけたらちょっと不自然ですね
綺麗すぎだやすい食べ物ですが
ハイパイ猫これも国家見てもまだサッカー本体がなんか透けてるんですか
これはお店まで世界ではいさすがですね year
いい県道クッキーがマジでリアルなんですよ
国家が見たらむずい確実なやつだけしていこう
フラフラんラフラこれはない方でちょっとカクついてたんでちょっと
に旋風か正解ああああなんだ
5連つ俺色が90自然ですこれ偽物です
正解うーん
からいいですよねおままごと読みたいじゃあ
5歳児用やちょっと難しくなってたっぷりカー
まとめて3つとも全部違いますあの僕最近カレーライス作った時に阿部が実際に触った
んでこんな大きいまぶりからないと思うんですよこれ違います店もです
せいか色々とはここをしっかりと押さえていく
ここをしっかりと押さえているさあ代目きましたよ
軍やペングレア早く4編はちょっとタッっとにこんな鮮やかなに弱くかってくらい無駄
に級の広いねこれは偽物です
by 並んたーーー
世界の欲しく同選挙区
たつん南郷て軽い方もちょっと怪し
気がするんだよなクッキーをちょっと最後にとっておきたい本気のかなもなかはお腹
自体あんまりされたことないからよくわかりませんもなんか分からないので偽物だと
思います
世界に乗った
やばいってこれ
やばいってこれもで作っていうかここが公園ですよろしくです
きゅうりであるすぎ強いんだけどもなんか綺麗な最近カレーを作る時使ったんですけど
いや
急に者の名前毛並みがおかしかったですちょっと思う
どうよね
正解です
[音楽]
gacchi で崩れいや何かイオンかんとかさん
あ様ができたものですねこれだから共鳴今しっかりな患者でちょっと感じなんすけど
若干
プラスチックが作り物感がある感じがありましたファインダーなぁサファイだなぁさ
ブーブー言っ
嫌気しましょうかんっ
違います
世界ですね
くーみんも怪しいいないこんな変な風に僕が見た分かりません組
偽物です
ん
分
世界を背負っ
何でん
いやーこんなグレネード流しろびかりしていってよい方たくなる店があるんですけど
こっからはずでなんかんよ
首都と舞いましたはいこっち側のチョコクッキー
これなんか雑貨作り物感といいますかチョコチップこんなデカイの苦情が来るような気
がするんですよね
寝たままです海からさふぁいあさん
ここま女子としての誇りが登りが発車類
いっ
いやー
いやーそのさあば昨季やばくに俺コレクターほどあるもうこれ
ムーンライトずやってこうなってるのうんムーンあきにゃー
桜ん坊の音さらに中水したっていうんだよなぁ
re ん
ん
まあまあまあまあけんかをしたんですそういう作成かも
3分水となることないもはこんなコートテックあるれたうん
分前には違うじゃこんなにする日介してなかった気がします今ない
ブルー日には
偽物ですございましたファイバーさあ世界です
ただもうもう良いよ
どうぞスープクッキーこっちさっきの1個目とはちょっと違うような気がするけど大体
の代表が出てるんでこれを多分にしたもの
フェイクだった気がしますこれ以上です
5なーさんファイナルアンサー正解ですねこれはからめっちゃ方がっぽいけれども
大したもんだよ
を怒られるなど水したかってるか出てるよ
いやでもさくらんぼたになりてるぜってー3カラムじゃんこれ
[音楽]
はいオッケーなんですぶどうの一番コツです情報中ですねこれ実際ものが気がします
特に理由はありません
背がありますマジかまたからも
食べちゃいます
[音楽]
濡れてる女ってそんな高度技術できる聞いたんですけどそこへざっくり長さんって言っ
てく
俺を押せ通れないけど
ますっっ
これ本文です
疑って行っちゃってくればまあどれでもそしてそれが本物でしたらしかにちょっと
ショップ君にから止めました
はい私
チェリーがいい
本能だと思ったんではい食べます
召し上がれ
[音楽]
ブーブーブーブーんっ
あこれに過ごせるような
うぇい残念マドルこの政治が版なんでございましたわー
あっきゅんベーコンなども行ってないと食ってしてくれればいい
えっ
これが俺がいい
それですいやーお菓子の名前ねやっぱてくると思ったけど
ブーバ祝うもう絶 yr pou dou dou だろうと思ったら大よアーズっ
気取って揺れたの聞いたかさっきそんなブーバーン夏っぽくんっ
いいかなと思ったんだけどこのブーツ型
めっちゃ綺麗な形が面積です ea 食品さんというかを醸し出してて俺はそこに言う
じゃなかった
ナカガーでもらえたんじゃマジでわからんだった